i want to start today with one of these
totally dystopian horror stories that's
framed in our modern cultural and
economic system as
entertainment or
something nice when in reality it is a
story that shows us just how bad things
are and i'm talking about this viral
story
of a cash scramble five thousand one
dollar bills laid out on an ice rink
in south dakota
where
during a hockey game during the sioux
falls stampede hockey game on saturday
night
teachers from nearby schools were
invited to grab as many dollar bills as
possible in less than five minutes and
the idea the point of this was
it's five thousand dollars that the
teachers can secure
to get supplies for their classrooms and
the money was of course donated not for
nothing it was a sponsorship cu mortgage
direct
donated the 5 000 in dollar bills in
exchange for sponsorship placement on
the event because they're so great and
it's an amazing thing that they're doing
so they get publicity out of it and the
idea is let the teachers go at it
picking up cash and not only is it
listen
of course it's demeaning to some degree
to send people out to pick up dollar
bills because it shows a certain degree
of
uh you know financial need that is often
stigmatized in
many cultures not just unique to the
united states the idea of you're
scrambling for dollar bills and stuffing
them in your pants and in your you know
wherever wherever it is that you're
stuffing them
there's you know the idea is that sort
of oh wow wow crap we're more refined
we're not so crass that we get on our
hands and knees for dollar bills so in
some sense there's that aspect to it but
then it's
teachers but teachers for money for
supplies for their classrooms and it's
another one of these stories where if
things were functioning correctly
this wouldn't be necessary you know that
the classic example breaking bad
tremendous television program
with brian cranston as walter white
as a high school science teacher
chemistry teacher who gets a diagnosis
of lung cancer
um and starts cooking meth
to not only pay for his treatment but to
leave some money for his family so it's
a signal of yes as a teacher he's
underpaid right because he needs to do
this in order to pay for the treatment
and leave some money to his family but
also in a country
that has
single-payer health care
universal health care of some kind you
don't need to go to cooking and selling
meth in order to pay for your medical
treatment so in many countries breaking
bad just never happens
these are similar stories to the ones
we've done where
little jimmy or little [ __ ] 7 years
old is raising money for susie's cancer
treatment and he's making brownies and
blondies and they're selling them at 75
cents each at school to fundraise for
susie's cancer treatment how lovely
what an amazing
show of
love and empathy and it is those things
but it is dystopian that it is even
necessary
why are seven-year-olds doing bake sales
to raise money for someone else's cancer
treatment or
machine this is another one i think this
might have been like a prosthetic
but the gist of the story was you know
local machine shop
welds a wheelchair for some kid
who can't afford the wheelchair and
whose parents can't afford it well we
had a differently organized medical
system you just get the wheelchair
because it's covered by social insurance
or whatever other system is put in place
and that is very similar to this entire
south dakota thing so like is it
demeaning to be crawling around on your
hands and knees for dollar bills sure
um if it were teachers crawling around
on hands and knees
for themselves for dollar bills then we
would say maybe the teachers aren't paid
enough okay but this was teachers
crawling around on hands and knees
to get a share of five grand
to get supplies
for their classrooms and so maybe we're
not properly funding education at least
in south dakota there are states where
education is relatively well funded
south dakota not a state known for
particularly good infrastructure
healthcare or educational funding so at
the end of the day
we don't seek to
take away
from the humanity
of the people doing the thing right when
little jimmy says
i want susie to get the cancer treatment
so i'm gonna do the bake sale jimmy's
doing a great thing that should be
praised
when the local machine shop says kid
can't afford a wheelchair we're gonna
weld one for that those are great acts
when teachers
want their students to have what they
need in the classroom so they say i'll
get on my hands and knees for dollar
bills and stick them in my bra and my
jock strap or whatever it is
they're doing a good thing they're doing
good thing but it is the system that has
failed if teachers
after you know four years of college
many of them two more years for a
master's degree maybe three
you end up on an ice rink wrestling for
dollar bills to pay for pencils we have
systems that have failed here and it's
horrifying and it's okay for us to say
that it's horrifying even if the
teachers are doing a great thing and you
know what
it's not even like the mortgage company
is a bad guy they put up the five grand
sure i mean they did it in exchange for
sponsorship it's still five grand it's a
systemic problem that continues to rear
its head in these dystopian
circumstances
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan quattro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving shower head starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just a hundred and
nineteen dollars but nebia is giving you
ten percent off when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video